THE STATE OF ANTI BIG TECH:
Nowaday’s it’s cool to hate on all big
tech companies.
Apple, overpriced.
Google, evil.
Facebook, lizard man.
Amazon, bald man.
And Netflix, well, according to the media,
they’re already dead.
Much of the criticism that these companies
receive is perfectly valid.
They do indeed collect user data, work to
keep us addicted to mind numbing content,
and some of them have a horrendous workplace.
But, while people like to complain about these
attributes, it’s not like anyone is switching
away from these companies right?
I mean, in terms of revenue, all of these
companies are at all times highs or near all
time high levels.
And in terms of market cap, even with the
stock market crash and tons of layoffs, all
of these compnaies are still worth hundreds
of billions if not trillions.
But, while these companies are still performing
extraordinarily well, there seems to be a
new movement within the tech industry that’s
also thriving: the anti-big tech tech industry.
Most of these companies don’t create anything
ground breaking or revolutionary.
They’re usually just rudimentary photo sharing,
emailing, or messaging services.
But, that’s ok because their value proposition
lies in what they don’t do.
DuckDuckGo doesn’t collect your browsing
data.
Signal doesn’t spy on your personal conversations.
And BeReal doesn’t serve you a constant
stream thirst traps and instagram thots.
Given the general distaste for big tech products,
a large number of people have embraced these
new platforms.
DuckDuckGo has 80 million users.
Signal has 40 million users.
And BeReal has 47 million users.
For a brief period of time, BeReal was even
the most downloaded app on the Apple App Store.
At this rate, these services can surely be
a viable alternative to big tech right?
Or at least, they should get big tech to change
some of their policies and tendencies, but
this is where the bad news comes in.
Just as fast as these apps rose in popularity,
they’re also crashing in popularity.
BeReal for example was able to reach an impressive
53 million installs, but only a mere 9% of
users actually use the app on a regular basis.
A similar story can be seen with Signal as
well.
While their total user count keeps souring,
their daily active users was actually down
60% by the end of 2021.
This is in stark contrast to big tech companies.
Though people apparently cannot stand their
practices, their user bases are stronger than
ever.
Google and Facebook literally have monthly
active user counts in the billions and it’s
only expected to go up.
So, here’s why anti big tech companies are
already failing.
ROCKY FOUNDATIONS:
People ditching these anti big tech apps may
seem like a new trend, but their eventual
demise can usually be traced back to the root
of their success.
You see, most of these apps don’t grow in
a very natural manner.
It’s not like they grow from 1 to 2 to 5
to 10 million users.
Rather, its more like, they have 5000 users
one months and then 10 million the next month
then back to 1 million a year after.
In other words, much of their popularity is
due to some sort of shortlived external surge.
Take Signal, for instance.
Signal has actually been out for nearly 10
years having been launched in July of 2014.
But, most of you probably didn’t hear about
Signal up until 2021 and that’s no coincidence.
Much of Signal’s popularity can be attributed
to a single tweet from Elon Musk: Use Signal.
The original tweet itself didn't go viral
only garnering a few hundred thousand likes,
but it got the attention of the media, social
media influencers, and eventually everyday
people.
And if you’re not convinced that this tweet
had much of impact, just take a look at Signal’s
monthly downloads.
As you can see, throughout 2020, Signal was
chilling at a few million downloads per month.
Suddenly in the first quarter of 2021 though,
when Elon made his tweet, it exploded to 80
million downloads.
But, within just one more quarter, Signal’s
downloads were back down to a slightly higher
baseline.
And by the end of the year, the majority of
the people who had joined in on this sudden
surge had already left.
A similar story can be see with BeReal as
well.
Most of us associate BeReal with 2022, but
the app actually launched at the start of
2020.
It wasn’t until a brilliant marketing effort
in 2022, however, that it actually blew up.
You see, Signal figured that most of their
potential user base was young adults.
And what’s the easiest way to get to these
people?
Well, the answer is college campuses.
In early 2022, BeReal started paying college
students to promote the app by writing about
in the school newspaper, hosting BeReal parties,
and sponsoring food.
As the app gained popularity amongst college
campuses, the mainstream media started picking
up on it and it really just snowballed from
there.
But, at the end of the day, the app’s entire
user base could be traced back to one successful
marketing campaign, and as that marketing
campaign lost steam, so did the app.
The same thing could be said about Clubhouse
as well.
In early 2021 when big name players like Elon
Musk jumped on, the platform went absolutely
wild, but within just one year, I mean just
look at the graph.
The reality is that while people love to complain
about big tech all day, it’s not until an
external factor pushes them that they actually
try something new whether that be an Elon
Musk tweet or a marketing campaign.
But, while such events are great a creating
buzz around the service, it doesn't build
a loyal user base.
People aren’t using BeReal or Clubhouse
for the messaging functionality or the chatting
functionality or the social media aspect.
Really, they don’t use it for any specific
purpose other than some celebrity is using
it or everyone around me is using it.
In other words, for most users, these apps
lack any real substance and are usually built
upon a pretty rocky foundation.
So, as soon as that external factor starts
to fade, so does the app.
BECOMING THE VILLAIN:
Most of these apps don’t survive the virality
boom, but even if they do, that’s just the
first step.
Now, these apps have to live up to the promise
of being better than big tech offerings.
Afterall, for many of them, that’s their
entire pitch.
BeReal is not another social media network.
Robinhood is investing for all.
And Signal is the private WhatsApp, though
ironically it was created by one of WhatsApp’s
founders.
The problem though is that it’s virtually
impossible to stick to such virtuosic visions.
I mean think about this.
At one point in time, Facebook and Google
themselves were the anti big tech players.
When Google launched, Yahoo, Microsoft, and
AOL dominated the search and browser scene.
And by the time Facebook launched, Friendster
and MySpace were ginormous.
Also, let’s not forget, Google’s entire
slogan was “Don’t Be Evil”.
But, both of these companies eventually turned
to the quote on quote dark side.
Why?
Well, I can assure you that it’s not because
they want to.
Do you think Mark Zuckerberg wants a 22% favorability
rating or that Google wants to be known for
invasive data collection?
Of course not.
The reason that these companies turn to such
means is because that is literally the only
way to do it for free.
The only viable alternative is to charge end
users.
But, if you wanna compete against free offerings
from big names, you have to also offer your
service for free and that’s were the problem
arises.
As an anti big-tech company, not only do you
have to offer your services for free to remain
competitive, but you have to do it while not
engaging in any of the lucrative revenue avenues
that the big tech companies engage in.
This may work out fine for the first few years
when you have momentum and a bunch of venture
capital, but eventually, you reach a crossroads
at which point, you realize that you have
a fundamental problem.
All of those big tech practices that your
app has disowned have led it to a dead end.
Take BeReal for instance.
The idea of the app is that users share a
simple photo of themselves everyday and that
they don’t spend hours endlessly scrolling
through other people’s photos.
But, bro, how the hell are you gonna make
money when you’re actively not just encouraging
but enabling your users to use the app for
as little time as possible and not collecting
any data on them.
Let’s just say most of these apps have a
harsh reality check when VC money dries up
and they have to continue paying for hundreds
of servers and thousands of engineers.
At this point, you only have 2 options.
Turn to the darkside and save the company
or continue pursuing your idealistic fantasy
and kill the company.
For obvious reasons, almost all founders and
leaders choose option 1 and before you know
it, you’ve become the villain that you sought
to eliminate.
FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED:
Virtually no company is able to survive the
virality boom and the funding crunch, but
hypothetically, let’s say some anti big
tech company manages to do this.
The reality is that they’re still screwed
because if the virality nor the funding took
down the company, the users will because the
service is fundamentally flawed as it opposes
human psychology.
Here’s the thing, while it’s easy to blame
big tech companies for everything that’s
wrong with their platforms, the truth is that
much of what’s wrong with their platform
is us.
Do you hate that your Instagram and TikTok
feed are filled with thirst traps or that
your YouTube feed is filled with clickbait
titles that the economy is ending as we know
it?
News flash, this is not because of big tech
companies.
These companies aren’t committed to showing
you any one thing.
The only thing they’re committed to is keeping
you on the platform.
So, the only reason your feed is filled with
thots is because that’s what you like to
see.
If you truly liked seeing documentaries about
kale and video essays about steel fabrication,
that’s what these platforms would show you.
Trust me, these social media platforms have
it down to a science and the almighty algorithm
is just audience psychology.
But, it turns out that you don’t like that.
You don’t want to see authentic photos of
your friends.
You want to see the highlight real because
that’s what gives you something to long
for, something to fantasize about.
While this is terrible for your mental health,
it’s also the most addictive and most engaging.
But by virtue, this also means that an app
that circulates authentic photos is non addictive
and non engaging.
And though you may know that this is better
for your mental health, most people don’t
end up sticking with this option.
It’s the same reason that most people gain
back weight that they lose from a diet and
why gyms are packed in January.
While such apps have a cool premise, the reality
is that they’re essentially a social media
diet, and sooner or later, most people stop
dieting.
THE FUTURE OF ANTI BIG TECH:
At the end of the day, the massive fall of
these anti big tech companies isn’t surprising.
These companies are trying to break the law
of physics by trying to do it all.
They want to offer the best parts of Google
and Facebook without paying the price, and
that’s simply impossible because nothing
comes for free.
If users aren’t paying with money, they
have to pay with their attention by watching
ads and by sacrificing their privacy.
It’s that simple.
That’s how a business works.
They offer a service or product for a price.
And if customers aren’t paying, the business
is simply not viable.
But, even if you somehow figured out the busines
side of things, you’ll be blocked by yet
another law of physics: attention cannot be
created or destroyed.
There’s a limited amount of attention out
there, and people like spending it on things
that they know they shouldn’t be spending
it on.
I mean, just think about it, the biggest restaurant
chain in the world isn’t a salad chain,
it’s a burger joint.
The same thing applies for tech.
The biggest tech companies will always be
the ones that feed into your negative tendencies
as opposed to the ones that try to oppose
them.
And that’s why these anti big tech companies
are already failing.
Would you ever attempt a big tech detox?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you would like to see
more tech oriented business videos.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.